how old were you uh
just at that time i was uh
21 or one between 21 and 22. wow
and that was interesting
uh we we talked about you know the
espionage about uh what's going on in
the world
uh and i i
i
from from early on i showed my
how honest i am you know i
told him about some weaknesses that i
thought i had
shyness with the girls stuff like that
and then he started giving me some tasks
so
for instance he would
drive me to a building and point to it
and say
uh see if you can find out who what
organization is in there there was no
nameplate no nothing
uh so i had to like uh
you know make friends with some people
who walked out the door after
after work end ended
i also one time was asked to
knock on the door of a
of a family
and have a talk with somebody who opens
the door to find out about their
relative in the west
and so that's uh
that's sort of false flag
interviews so i pretended to be a
sociology student
and came with a uh um
with a survey i asked him
could you answer some survey questions
pretty innocent but sounded good
and as we were talking somehow i find a
way to
sort of talk about west germany and make
it into a little bit of a social
conversation and you wouldn't believe
how easily people volunteer stuff that
that you want to get out of them
so i i didn't like doing this because
you know my shyness
got sort of in the way but i couldn't
fail no failure was not not an option
for me
so um
over
and and i believe uh
you know this herman guy
um eventually determined that i am
a really good candidate
so
he uh he
got in touch with berlin the
headquarters of uh kgb in east germany
and they invited me for a three-week
visit to berlin
that was my first uh
you know trip as an as it would be agent
because i wasn't
i was given
a
code name a code phrase a time and a
place where we would meet
and so i would go and
find that place in berlin and meet
my new
friend who introduced himself as boris
i worked with boris for
about three weeks he gave me tasks to do
and he also gave me
west german literature to read
their spiegel desten uh you know the
things that were forbidden you you were
not allowed to have them and almost
nobody did so that
made me feel good because you know i was
already i had i had
one foot outside the law and uh but
and you know having always been a
contrarian wanted to be different from
everybody else that that that was very
uh
flattering
how long how long did your spy training
last with them and then at what point
how long did it take for you to be
deployed to the united states okay so
the base training was two years that was
their standard training period
uh i i was already working as a
assistant professor in college when
they finally made me the offer then on
the last day in berlin i got the offer
and within a month i quit the university
and uh moved to berlin
by the way
that will be interesting to
to know
uh in those days uh in east germany
good apartments and
nice houses to live in were where
so here i am you know i'm now
in the kgb i go to berlin
i would expect the key to a nice
apartment
so i meet my my new handler the boss
that i had for the two years in berlin
and uh
his name was nikolai
uh interestingly he was ukrainian
and we talk in his car and then he says
i have a task for you that's your first
task
find yourself a place to stay
now
he knew and i knew everybody knew that
all
apartments and houses were
under the control of the government
there was a waiting list up to 10 years
to get get an apartment for a couple
with a child
it was impossible to just go and rent an
apartment so
i could have failed this was a
pass fail task
if i can't find an apartment
if i can't find a place to stay they
don't want me i needed to
show my ability to improvise
yeah but i i did and uh i
i figured the further away from berlin i
get
the law for chance i have i i drove
i took the city train to the last stop
to a town called akna and knocked on
doors and asked if somebody had
had a room
eventually i found a place uh
it was an out building
it was
made out of brick but it had and it had
two
rooms one had a bed and a chair
and the other one has a had a wood
burning stove
and running cold water and that's where
i lived for six months wow yeah
so the training
after six months
i think nikolai determined yeah this guy
is a keeper so he gave me a key to an
apartment
so uh the training in berlin was uh two
years and i was going to be the part b
departing for west germany after two
years
one of the things i was required to do
everybody they told me everybody has to
have to learn a foreign language
all right
and they gave me a choice i said well i
speak english english was easy for me in
school you know i i i went with straight
a's without studying
and uh
i
like with everything else i threw myself
i gave myself 100 into learning english
i
i mean i became a maniac and
within like
eight seven eight months
i had enough enough of a vocabulary to
be able to read english novels without a
dictionary
every word that i when i read stuff
every new word i wrote down and i
learned
it came to about a hundred words a day i
counted them
and so one day uh some guy from moscow
comes to visit and he asked me how's
your english and i said well i pulled a
book out and said i can read that no
problem
and he said what
all right um we're going to get you a
tape recorder and you just uh
tape tape a message you can talk about
anything you want
so a week later i get the tape recorder
i give it back to nikolai he sends it to
moscow a week later i was on a plane
to moscow
because they had heard enough
to think that there's a possibility
that i have enough talent to
learning american english well enough
to have nothing but a slight accent left
that can easily be explained
so uh in moscow i met with a
with a college professor who uh russian
who taught english and and a born
american and we had we talked for about
two hours
and afterwards they discussed it between
the two of them and it was
uneven the the russian
figured nah he can't do it and the
american typica typical american uh
optimism
i can teach him
so
bingo now they they had a potential
asset somebody they could they could put
into the ranks of the main adversary
that's what the kgb called the united
states
as an illegal so
i was moved to moscow
to get another two and a half years
training and then before i
they they could launch me
with the right documentation it took
another half year so i spent five years
in training
wow
i